[Music]
ashley graham is proudly showing off her
new tummy there is no perfect body and
that we shouldn't be striving for
perfection anymore you should be happy
in your own skin the 34 year old model
who gave birth to twin boys in january
shares new photos of herself posing
topless in front of a mirror in the
first pick ashley is wearing black
underwear and holding her chest as she
shows the stretch marks on her stomach
the entrepreneur gives us a close-up
shot of her belly and here's another one
the proud mama making a silly face and
keeping it real she writes in the
caption hi new tummy we've been through
a lot thank you hashtag three months
postpartum i really believe that you
should be bold in life don't be afraid
in january ashley and her husband justin
irvin announced that they welcomed their
newborn sons a month later the couple
revealed their special names malachi and
roman and wrote on instagram my boys
have been the greatest teachers and
biggest reminders that i can do hard
things this has not been easy but it's
so worth it still can't believe i have
three children is this like real life
right now of course ashley and justin
were already proud parents to their
first son isaac who was born in january
2020 but his baby brothers they didn't
arrive exactly on their due date prior
to giving birth ashley let fans know how
she was feeling on tick-tock
[Music]
and during her pregnancy with babies
number two and three the podcast host
opened up to et about prepping for their
growing family you know i always heard
that number two you're a lot more tired
you show faster i mean it's happening
it's like you know i start i popped
really fast i'm exhausted i'm running up
after a toddler so yes all the
stereotypical things i don't know if
there is much preparation that can
really go in for baby number two i mean
i feel like i did so much preparation
when it came to isaac
and almost to the degree that like i
might maybe over prepared so i'm i'm
just making sure that i have the
supplies that i need which is basically
nothing like i just like i look at my
boobs i'm like okay check check we got
this just need some newborn diapers
check check
and um
i'm just not going to overthink it as
for little isaac becoming a big brother
ashley said he didn't fully understand
the concept just yet i said do you know
where the baby is and then he points to
my stomach so we got that farm and then
sometimes he wants to kiss the baby so
he goes like this
he like curls his top lipid and bottom
lip out it's really sweet so we got that
far but i don't think he understands
like the big brother aspect
[Music]